so is it okay to kill babies and
children so we God say in the Bible to
kill babies and children it right or
wrong I don't there's nothing about I'll
show you you didn't know that I'll show
you I'll show
you
hold I'm going to show you to
read
to
[Music]
godp if you
read now go attack and attack the
malachit and totally destroy all that
that belongs to them they not spare them
death men women and children
here
the can are the Arab and for the last 5
years more that what the
are they following the Bible so you
condemn it for baby we should
not no you condemn God for say to kill
babies and children well this is wrong
yeah so God was wrong God is not never
wrong yeah but God said it here read
what this is what men says no you don't
the
Bible alhamdulillah so you become
muslow come here howd you go man